hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video auf meinem kanal meine lieben
freunde des bereits im titel
eingeblendet wir machen heute einen
nicht lachen challenge allerdings
schauen wir uns nicht einfach irgendeine
compilation mit lustigen clips nein das
wäre zu einfach und zwar hat meine
freundin jule mir einige - rausgesucht
einige sprach nachrichten von freunden
einige clips einige bilder einige wenige
eigentlich hätten einfach 20
verschiedene dinge rausgesucht von denen
sie denken dass ich darüber lachen wer
hat also ich würde sagen wir fangen
direkt an das hier meine damen und
herren ist sandra und immer wenn sander
uns in köln besucht hat sie zwei drei
stunden zug fahren hinter sich von daher
stinken ihre füße immer besonders krank
nach verwesung deswegen zwingen will
sandra immer wenn sie nach köln kommt
direkt ihre füße zu waschen
und ich würde sagen das war noch kein
richtiges lassen wir machen wir weiter
mit dem nächsten video oder bild oder
keine ahnung was apropos sandra soeben
ist auch ein neuer podcast online
gegangen auch spotify apple music dieser
keine ahnung wo man beim podcast kann
und in der video beschreibung ist auf
jeden fall linke zusammen ich rede in
der folge war unsere kindheit also wenn
ihr bock habt kriegt dann nach dem video
gern mal draufhalten jetzt gehts weiter
mit dem nächsten nicht sein ding
[Musik]
da hab ich sonder augenmaske gemacht
gegen augenringe hast du scheiße ist das
bild so lockt ein jahr alt so hat die
denn diese ganzen sachen erde waren in
vingst an der nordsee im urlaub und ich
habe einfach eine freundin von uns an
gefunden denn der größte penner wenn man
sich meine videos anschaut alkohol
alkohol alkohol
da muss ich nicht lachen das war eine
freundin von uns carola in unserer
gruppe geschickt hat unsere whatsapp
gruppe und die wolfs habe ich
gespeichert und julia die dann irgendwie
wieder gefunden
also ich kannte die vision von der fall
sei warum das denn jetzt trotzdem es ist
übrigens zu beginnen mal kurz ein
bisschen schwarz wenn ich mir sachen
hier anschaue
weil jude mir die sache mit
schnittprogramm reingezogen hat so dass
sich die hat definitiv nicht vorher sehr
und dann gehe ich halt an die stelle
bevor die clips zum warum niemand
echte sind alles glänzt die alle schon
gerne und trotzdem stetig und lag bei
einem sommerurlaub mit freunden was
trinken und danach dachte ich irgendwie
ich bin voll schnell keine ahnung ist
nach hause gelaufen weil wir nicht enden
gehen wollten ich dachte wer schneller
als usain bolt und ich weiß zu juden
fehlen mich mal ich höre ich bin
ultraschnell dann doch nicht so beruhigt
dich leute das wird beim konzert ihrer
schule wird sie als patrick verkleidet
wie man unschwer erkennen kann
sie hat ihr habe ich nicht mal bestanden
aber nicht so war die verkleidung gutes
ende haben
[Musik]
sandra ich sehe hier schon dass die
nächste tat eine audiodatei ist also ich
würde sagen wir hören jetzt mal zusammen
rein halten
ja das war wieder sandra aber ich muss
nicht lachen
[Musik]
ist die wahrheit alter ich verstehe
wirklich nicht warum man immer jede
schulklasse den biologieunterricht schon
mal ein tier auseinandergenommen
ich habe es nie verstanden alter
[Musik]
das habe ich gemacht dass eigentlich
alle so traubenzucker dann hab ich das
halt runter geschrieben und ihr gesicht
ein bisschen verarbeitet also ich weiß
nicht warum ich jetzt gerade so gelacht
haben
daher hat das mini deshalb von mir aber
gut wir machen wir weiter aber gut meine
damen und herren ich würde sagen wir
kommen nun auch zum letzten video dass
jule für mich ausgesucht hat also mal
schauen ob ich hier jetzt auch lachen
muss
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob es irgendein von euch
auch so geht aber bei mir ist es so
immer wenn ich mir von einer sache video
auf youtube an kuka empfiehlt mir
youtube tausendfach ähnliche videos
ich habe mir letztens ein kakadu video
angeschaut seitdem sind alle meine
empfehlungen auf youtube voll mit kakadu
videos und kakadus und so lustige tiere
letztens habe ich eingesehen aber
einfach übel sondern die ganze zeit
herum geschrieben
geprüft werden sollte wäre ich mir auf
jeden fall ein kakadu kaufen handel
stellt euch das heutige video allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
euch dieses mal etwas anderen nicht
lachen challenge gefallen hat damit ich
mich sehr über einen daumen hoch von
euch unten in den kommentaren freuen
ja wahrscheinlich gibt hier in den
kommentaren dem video einen daumen hoch
aber wir kennen main kanal falls sie
noch kein teil der luxus sei das ist
kostenlos und verpasst keine videos mehr
und feierte schon abonnent seid dann
klickt dann auf die glocke denn dann
bekommt er eine benachrichtigung sobald
ein neues video online gehen
[Musik]